découverte aussi peut-être d'amande que
vous ne connaissez pas beaucoup le monde
polaire version pré manar dans un
endroit assez surprenant qu'est ce que
vous diriez à celles et ceux qui ne
connaissent pas l'endroit stéphane
niveau mais déjà c'est de venir
bien évidemment de découvrir le coin
parce que il ya l espace d monde polaire
m'ont aussi une station une station de
ski
oui sans succès les roues sans grand
éclat et en ce moment c'est juste
magique a du soleil de la neige et tout
ce qu'il faut pour venir apprécier le le
haut jura et en plus on peut découvrir
toute la glace parce que c'est ça le
pitch finalement de cet espace d monde
polaire cesser la glace en s'amusant il
ya des lumières
il ya des images à du multimédia ya
plein de choses avec lui à plein de
choses il ya une patinoire une patinoire
en glace la seule patinoire en glace du
département du jura
donc en fait l'idée était d'associer à
ce qui est un pari à la basse et
d'associer un espace muséographique un
espace ludique avec une patinoire est en
fait le public que l'on ac est un public
familial permet à certains de la famille
d'aller faire le musée pendant que les
autres s'amusent sur la glace et tout en
s'amusant sur la glace on continue à
passer des images polaire que ce soit
arctique ou antarctique des images en
noir et blanc de paul emile victor donc
ça reste aussi un outil de médiation
ismaël agnès vous connaissez cet endroit
l'espace des mondes polaire pas du tout
pas du tout voilà une nouvelle
découverte pendant 15 ans comme ça ne va
pas tarder pour aller jouer sur les
réponses vous donner un ordre d'idée il
ya à peu près 1000 personnes
après manon mille habitants l'espace des
mondes polaire ça représente 60 mille
visites par an et ce n'est que le début
ce n'est que le début ça fait pas deux
ans qu'on a inauguré le bâtiment donc on
est encore en phase ii de peinture
encore un peu un peu mythique à quelques
endroits
donc ça fait bientôt ça fera deux ans
cet été donc l'été oui c'est ça juillet
donc on est encore encore en rodage même
si on avait déjà testé le bâtiment avant
l'ouverture au public
mais c'est vrai que c'est un bel outil
pour un pour un village de 1000
habitants
et puis vous faites régulièrement des
expos temporaires nous l'image qu'on est
en train de voir là avec cette fameuse
expo avec ce nom qui qui moi me ravit
ses poils plumes crottes
je trouve ça excellent ça pourrait
presque être un sujet pour la ligue
d'impro 1 ça parce qu'il y aurait de
quoi faire il ya beaucoup de cartons
qu'est ce que c'est que cette exposition
stéphanie web et l'originalité cette
exposition comme on le voit sur le
visuel c'est qu'en effet on peut aussi
l'appeler tout en carton dans une
exposition qui était l'idée c'était en
fait de sortir un peu du kitsch et des
cuisses des clichés d'essayer de
reproduire un décor
avec du polystyrène ou autre et là en
fait l'idée du carton est arrivé et et
j'avoue que au départ c'était un peu ce
n'était pas forcément évident à lui dans
l'imaginer il ya quand même 20 mètres
cubes de cartons donc tout ça dans 200
m² et ben voilà l'idée c'était à c'était
une manière de transporter aussi le
visiteur mais aussi l'enfant dans cet
univers puisque pour le coup on
reproduit un univers pour l'enfant pour
qu'il puisse s'amuser un espèce de
labyrinthe où on reproduit différents
biotype biotope donc après il ya les
adultes évidemment qui viennent se
greffer là-dessus pour apporter un
message cohérent et et scientifique qui
est en fait de montrer que dans le dans
la nature dans le milieu naturel on
pouvait retrouver les traces des animaux
et comprendre ce que l'on avait sous les
yeux à condition de savoir regarder on
pourrait sous titré finalement bienvenu
dans le monde incroyable de la faune
sauvage c'est ce dimanche
oui c'est très bien très bien vu donc on
a préféré poils plumes crottes parce
qu'on n'était plus assez montrent que
c'est aujourd'hui parce que noir et
chemise blanche pour moi c'est pas tous
les jours comme ça et donc voilà donc
l'idée c'était s'était en effet à
travers ce titre c'était aussi d'amuser
parce que voilà on voulait pas être non
plus sérieux même si le le sujet de fond
reste sérieux c'est partir à la
découverte de et comprendre d'accord des
traces et des indices dans le milieu
matériel pour tous ces animaux
évidemment on retrouve ces traces
forcément à l'extérieur vous lisent
efforts méritoires actuellement il ya du
soleil et de la neige donc j'imagine que
les parents comme les enfants peuvent
s'amuser en sortant finalement roja
retrouver peut-être pas les maîtres
qu'on va les retrouver dans le monde
polaire mais en tout cas d'autres bêtes
mais d'autres bêtes en tout cas celle
que l'on peut observer facilement dans
le haut jura on a mis les traces dans
l'exposition et l'idée le pari c'est que
en effet si les personnes en sortant de
l'exposition un regard différent et
s'amuse à chercher dans le milieu
naturel mais même simplement à la sortie
du bâtiment a retrouvé les traces dans
le milieu et bien c'est pari gagné on a
écouté je pense qu'il yad'autres paris a
à gagner dans la région bourgogne
franche comté quand on aime le froid on
parlait d'enfants
on va rester finalement avec eux j'ai
bien compris que les expos et notamment
le monde polaire ça plaît beaucoup aux
enfants
franchement ça devrait pas nous déplaire
aussi même si vous ne connaissez pas je
vous invite à aller faire un petit tour
après manon et aussi peut-être aussi à
la saline royale d'arc et senans où le
froid est à l'honneur
pour l'occasion nous allons suivre
camille et puis nous revenons ensemble
du côté de l'espace des mondes polaire
après maintenant regarde les mollets
long manteau c'est parti pour affronter
le froid le froid mais de quel froid
parle-t-on au juste l'exposition d'arc
et senans le décline sous toutes ses
températures du froid polaire au froid
du frigo de la vie quotidienne à la
planète en passant par l'industrie
difficile de tout comprendre pour camus
on s'y est introduit et fred signes de
meilleure qualité qu'un produit surgelé
alors pour vulgariser un peu
l'exposition mise sur l'interactivité et
le juge parce que que je range les
aliments d'afrique et qu'est ce que tu
veux
les leaders en 1re agencement de frigo
pour kelly une performance jugée par
l'expert du froid également guide de
l'exposition
et selon lui c'est un quasi sans faute
même si il y à des erreurs à ne plus
commettre
en revanche les tomates elles perdent
leur goût si on les met au frigo même
dans le bac à légumes c'est reste ça
reste pas la bonne option
on a des choses très théoriques et des
choses très pratique de la vie
quotidienne une exposition très large
avec beaucoup de thèmes va tantôt être
attiré par le tardigrade qui est le
champion de la résistance au froid
tantôt être touché par un récit des
explorateurs au grand nord tantôt
préféré finalement joué un jeu sur la
chaîne du froid pour essayer de
rapporter nos pizzas surgelées au
supermarché sans qu'elle ait un autre
défi attend désormais camille choisir
parmi toutes ces matières quelle est
celle qui résistera le plus sale hiver
sans surprise la doudoune et la plus
efficace là on sent pas le vent ou un
cache-cou 30 et le vrai froid camille
repart la tête pleine bien couverte pour
l'hiver les rigolote cette petite
camille une plongée dans l'univers du
froid la saline royale d'arc et senans
c'est jusqu'au 22 avril
quant à l'expo poils plumes crottes mais
cette fois ci à l'espace des mondes
polaire à prémanon dans le jura sur la
station des rousses c'est jusqu'à quand
jusqu'au mois de novembre novembre 2009
on a le temps de s'y rendre ça nous
coûte combien ça va vous coûter 4 euros
4 ou 5 euros ça va dépendre du ticket
que vous avez à l'entrée et parce qu'il
ya aussi la patinoire il se transforme
en banquise il ya le musée ya les
collections il ya plein de choses même
chose il ya un bistrot polaire aussi un
restaurant où il ya des dessins ouvrir
des ateliers pédagogiques également donc
il ya vraiment de quoi faire et de quoi
visiter et vous apprenez même des
nouveaux mots vous savez ce que c'est
vous agnès et ismaël un hymne aux log il
étudie les niches non pas du tout hamish
ne veut que c'est quoi cette technolog
way un technologue c'est quelqu'un qui
va étudier justement les empreintes les
traces laissées dans le milieu naturel
ça tombe bien pour l'exposition poils
plumes crottes